good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-015 ject class
Keter special containment procedures SCP
oh one six is to remain within the
confines of a 5 meter cubed room and all
times maintained at a temperature not to
exceed zero degrees Celsius SCP o16
itself is to remain in the petri dish in
the containment cube at all times unless
directed otherwise by level for ro5
personnel full documentation of
experimentation with SCP l16
must be submitted before and after
samples and duplicates of scp-162
failure to follow these procedures will
result in termination or reassignment as
Class D personnel only authorized
personnel may be permitted to obtain
samples of and experiment with SCP Oh
1:6 under BCL 5 containment conditions
if an outbreak does occur despite the
following after mentioned procedures
directive base personnel are to
implement a code Sigma lockdown and
containment plan infected personnel are
to be terminated on site by security
forces wearing standard mission oriented
protective posture anti biological and
anti chemical equipment should the
infection not be contained after 48
hours the on-site nuclear device is to
be detonated remaining personnel are not
to be evacuated under any circumstances
as CP l16 has been shown to survive for
up to six hours on hard surfaces and up
to several minutes in air high intensity
ultraviolet light and high
concentrations of ortho allowed the
height solution have been demonstrated
to be effective in disinfecting
non-organic surfaces description SCP oh
one six is a blood-borne pathogen
recovered from a mine worker at who
injured himself while working on a deep
coal seam said wound became contaminated
with coal dust from the mine possibly
infecting the worker with dormant spores
over the next several days as CP 1 6 /
seeded to infect the remaining employees
at the mining camp as well as the CDC
Crisis Team dispatched to deal with the
epidemic foundation personnel then took
over the investigation and terminated
all affected personnel patient zero was
brought into captivity and the mineshaft
was collapsed by explosive device SCP oh
one six has an incubation period ranging
from 24 hours to 2 years depending on
the presence and number of other human
hosts in the area first symptoms
resemble the common cold and include
itchy eyes runny nose coughing and
bodily aches phase 2 begins in 48 hours
and consists of a controlled form of
hemorrhagic fever as the organism causes
a small amount of blood to become
aspirated in the lungs creating an
aerosol effect during phase 3 the host
crashes and bleeds out bleeding
profusely from every bodily orifice
including the nose tear ducts anus skin
pores mouth urethra and in cases of
female's vagina blood pressure
skyrockets during the final stage hosts
have been observed projectile vomiting
blood to distances of over five meters
should the host survive this near total
exsanguination the pathogen will become
dormant once more returning to the
incubation phase what distinguishes a CP
Oh 1:6 from other strains of hemorrhagic
fever such as a Boland Marburg is it's
unusual response to high stress should
the subject undergo a high-stress
situation such
as a life-threatening crisis the
organism will change its survival tactic
from rapid reproduction to the rewriting
of the hosts DNA and stimulation of
rapid cell division major physiological
changes occur within the first 24 hours
with complete bodily reconstruction
occurring within 2 weeks time most hosts
do not survive the process due to the
heavy demands made on the body an
interesting side effect of the
transformation is an increased
aggressive urge it is believed that this
may be an attempt to maximize the spread
of the virus in a similar manner to
rabies on another note subjects who
undergo bodily transformation no longer
appear to exhibit SCP oh one six is
hemorrhagic properties however subjects
infected by transformed hosts will still
undergo the normal SCP o one six
infection process addendum experiment
log of SCP oh one six is transformative
properties subject do one six one
d-class personnel infected by SCP oh one
six upon first showing symptoms subjects
quarters were slowly flooded with water
over a 24-hour period SCP oh one six
mutated into a terror - morphix state
transforming subjects lungs into gills
subject survived for two more weeks as a
CPL one six transformed its limbs into
fins caused its eyes to atrophy and
enhanced its sense of hearing into a
cetacean type echolocation ability
subject was terminated by draining all
water from its quarters causing it to
his fixie aid body was subsequently
cremated without an autopsy
subject deal one six two d-class
personnel infected by a CP oh one six
upon first showing symptoms subjects
quarters were slowly flooded with water
over a 24-hour period SCP oh one six
mutated into a teratoma Orphic state
causing subject to undergo rapid
muscular growth and increased bone
growth on knuckles subject then
attempted to escape from confinement by
punching through the reinforced steel
door subject was not successful and died
by drowning note the same situation two
different responses interesting doctor
subject deal one six three d-class
personnel infected by SCP oh one six
subject was previously a chemical
engineer who poisoned his wife upon
discovering her adultery upon first
showing symptoms subjects quarters were
slowly flooded with water over a 24-hour
period the subject oh one six mutated
into a teratoma '[ __ ] state causing
subject to grow an unusual organ on his
chest
consisting of a chamber and two separate
tubes organ continued to take in water
and swell in size until foundation
personnel realizing what SCP l16 may be
attempting terminated the subject by
gunshot organ was found to contain
several gas sacks filled with acetylene
gas and oxygen subject oh one six for
d-class personnel infected by SCP oh one
six subject was told to concentrate on
forming wings no stress was applied SCP
oh one six did not mutate into a terror
to morphic state the subject died of
exsanguination during phase three
subject deal one six five d-class
personnel infected by SCP oh one six
subject was told to concentrate on
forming wings and placed in an acrylic
box suspended 305 metres above a mine
shaft a timer was placed outside the box
which subject was told indicated the
time to release SCP oh one six mutated
into a teratoma '[ __ ] state causing
subject to grow a tentacle like organ on
his left wrist similar to his spiders
spinnerets subject extended said organ
through one of the boxes air holes and
extruded a strong silk like substance
which it then used to secure the box to
the cable subject was terminated when
the countdown reached zero and the bomb
detonated okay why hasn't there been
more testing done on this way no I
losing my mind it's essentially an
adaptive mutagen right how useful would
that be it's probably above my pay grade
anyway thank you for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob government Jim's Sabha arbiter
Sewell
dr. bright darius time Justin day Oh
philia gray dur nom alex hill and j vu
Jack Cory barker Arun in and dr. Proctor
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you